[Music]
on this sunday night
defending the rcmp in nova scotia
the feds deploy more mounties to the
lobster dispute
we want to ensure that they have the
resources to be effective
but is it too late for a fishing
community that's so split
the president versus the governor the
president is
at it again how the election fight in
michigan is playing out
plus why the 2020 election matters our
mike armstrong
is in pennsylvania and the camp out for
cause
it's very cold a ten-year-old boy's
tribute
to a friend
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with the heated
fight over lobster fishing in nova
scotia
tensions are so high between indigenous
and commercial fishers
that there have been violent
confrontations and dangerous
incidents considered criminal more
mounties have arrived to try and take
down the pressure of this complicated
conflict
abigail beeman has our top story
a strong show of support for migma
fishers more than a thousand people in
this halifax square
our nation is in danger the racism is
thriving throughout magma
when you have to wake up every morning i
worry about your family
you will understand while on the coast
more rcmp are on the ground to help in
the conflict between
indigenous and non-indigenous fishers
ottawa approved the request after the
massive suspicious fire at this
lobster pound the sabinaqvi first
nations chief says he's seen more
officers but it's not enough
our main concern is the water we have
people out there that are
exercising the right and that's being
infringed upon
and there's no one there to ensure their
safety just watch it no
update on charges in the lobster pound
fire but rcmp have now charged one man
in the case of a separate car
fire tuesday chief mike sack was glad to
hear it
but says there have been all kinds of
criminal acts and threats
someone needs to be held accountable for
what's going on and right now nobody is
police and the federal government have
been criticized for being slow to act
with tensions simmering
long before this week there's been
vandalism arson
violence and assaults that have taken
place and that's completely unacceptable
there's a very complicate complicated
issue being resolved there
looking at what's in an interview on the
west block the public safety minister
defended the rcmp
the officers down there know that they
have a very difficult job to do
and and and they're doing you know what
is necessary but we want to ensure that
they have the resources
to be effective abigail beeman global
news
ottawa to the hostility on the u.s
campaign trail donald trump rallied in
michigan last night where he renewed his
attack on governor gretchen whitmer
the democrat has been a frequent target
over her state's covet-19 restrictions
earlier this month there was a foiled
plot to kidnap the governor
so trump encouraging calls to lock
whitmer up
are concerning as jennifer johnson
reports the trump campaign says the
president
was just having fun
a familiar battle cry at a trump rally
in battleground michigan but this time
the target was governor gretchen whitmer
not 2016 opponent hillary clinton u.s
president donald trump still stoking
fury against whitmer
10 days after the fbi arrested 13 people
including members of a militia group
and a plot to allegedly kidnap and
possibly kill her
i guess they said she was threatened
right
and she blamed me the president has
mocked whitmer for months
over partially closing her state to
prevent the spread of covet 19.
the governor says the president is
inciting domestic terrorism
it is wrong it's got to end it is
dangerous not just for me and my family
but for public servants everywhere who
are doing their
jobs and trying to protect their fellow
americans
trump's senior campaign advisor and
daughter-in-law
is defending his rhetoric he was having
fun at a trump rally of course
he wasn't encouraging people to threaten
this woman that's ridiculous whitmer's
policy to stop coven 19 have the state
so divided
she has banned the right to openly carry
guns at polling places
on election day you got to get your
governor to open up your state
okay new cases of copen 19 in michigan
are rising by over 2
000 a day almost every other u.s state
is also showing rapid increases in cases
and hospitalizations on the campaign
trail democratic presidential candidate
joe biden
won't let voters forget who's
responsible for the pandemic
my grandfather would say this guy's gone
around the bend if he thinks we turn the
corner
turn the corner things are getting worse
he continues to lie to us about the
circumstances
both candidates with completely
different views on how america can
recover from the pandemic
as voters decide in just over two weeks
which direction they want the country to
go
jennifer johnson global news washington
the u.s election may be one of the most
acrimonious in recent history but
there's something shared by supporters
of both campaigns
interest according to a recent poll
there's almost no difference in
how much democrats and republicans are
following the campaign
whether they're pulling for joe biden or
donald trump
a majority say they're more interested
in politics now
than in 2016. mike armstrong is in
pennsylvania tonight looking at
why voters are so engaged one sign
if i could just have you guys fill out
the form over here
to watch her work you'd assume she's an
old pro
but as it turns out melissa lee
boutillier says she's
never gotten involved in politics until
this election
and she's gone all in i'm out every day
yeah how many days a week five six
you know and even at home i'm still
doing it
there is a feeling in this election that
there's a lot on the line
on main street in downtown scranton the
trump office
is just two doors down from the biden
office at both
people say this election is different i
would say that i'm paying more attention
to this election than the past
i think this one is probably to me is
more important than any other lessons
that i ever you know
was involved in a recent pew poll found
78 percent of democrats say they're
following the campaign
quite a lot republicans were just as
engaged at 77
what may have people so interested is
that many don't just
prefer their candidate they're also
nervous
about what happens if the other side
wins even
scared well the reason being is that
there are people that want to change the
way america functions
i mean they want to turn our country
into a socialist country
so how does this campaign compare to
others well according to pew in the 2000
election
50 percent of registered voters felt it
really matters who wins
five elections later that number has
ballooned to 83 percent
it doesn't surprise me at all i think
people feel passionately
most people are paying attention this
time yeah
but the red wave will crush it now the
trump campaign is focused hard on
keeping its base motivated while the
biden campaign is having to fight
complacency
being ahead in the polls doesn't mean
anything if your supporters don't show
up and vote
and put a couple signs right there it
may not be an
issue that wins this election but
engagement
mike armstrong global news
scranton pennsylvania to the kova 19
pandemic in canada
two major toronto hospitals have now
declared outbreaks
st joseph's health center and toronto
western hospital say several units in
their facilities
are affected 29 people are infected at
st
joseph's including 13 staff at toronto
western hospital
three patients and five staff have
tested positive
since october 15th here's a look at the
new covenant 19 cases reported across
the country
today quebec reported nearly 1100 new
infections ontario has 658
44 people in manitoba have tested
positive
24 in saskatchewan there were five
additional cases in new brunswick
and two in nova scotia british columbia
and alberta
won't report new numbers until tomorrow
global news has obtained internal
federal government polling
it was done just before the trudeau
government pro-roped parliament
and before it presented the throne
speech our chief political correspondent
david aiken has the details on the poll
and how it may have influenced this
false political agenda
david well robin this poll was prepared
in june and global news got it through
an
access to information request it was
prepared at a time when the trudeau
government was coming to the end of a
politically turbulent summer including a
controversial decision
to pro-rogue parliament as the
government considered its fall policy
agenda
the polling data would have helped set
the government's priorities
it found that the issue canadians wanted
the federal government to pay the
greatest
attention to was not surprisingly the
coronavirus
followed by health care and the economy
just 2.5 percent thought climate change
should get the most attention
that is in sharp contrast to a similar
poll
also obtained by global news from a year
earlier
in july 2019 climate change
topped the list of issues that voters
wanted ottawa to pay attention to
followed by health and the economy
those findings may have prompted the
trudeau government to ease back
on plans that summon cabinet were
pushing for to use the covet 19 crisis
as a chance for more rapid and more
aggressive plans to lower greenhouse gas
emissions
but the poll also showed that the focus
of aaron o'toole and the conservatives
that the federal government should
deal with the rising deficit well that
might have been out of touch with
most voters just 2.7 percent of
respondents said
debt or deficits should get the greatest
attention from ottawa
and when asked to tick off some of the
top priorities for the federal
government
just 26 percent checked off federal
deficit
indeed the polls found canadians had
other top priorities for the federal
government
leading the way vaccine development
followed by
securing long-term care homes and then
securing canada's food supply and sure
enough the speech from the throne
did focus heavily on the health and
economic response to the covet 19
crisis the green recovery that theme
while it was in there if only in a
passing way
as for any concerns about debt and
deficits
that wasn't anywhere on the trudeau
government's radar
robin david aiken in ottawa thanks david
members of toronto's azerbaijani
community took to the streets in a show
of solidarity and to demand an end to
the three weeks of hostilities
in the region of nagorno-karabakh
the protesters called for armenia to
withdraw its armed forces from the area
which is legally recognized
as part of azerbaijan but largely
controlled by ethnic
armenians both countries blame each
other for the dispute and accuse one
another
of targeting civilians in the conflict
any sign of peace in nagorno-karabakh
began
to wither within minutes of a new
cease-fire that went into force
yesterday
the truce to exchange prisoners and
recover bodies began
at midnight local time but it was
quickly marred by shelling and rocket
fire
it's the second cease-fire agreement to
be broken
in a week more than 700 people have been
killed since the fighting broke out last
month
that includes nearly a hundred civilians
at least 13 people have been killed in a
suicide car bombing in afghanistan
the powerful blast happened near a
police station in the western province
of gore
several government buildings and stores
were destroyed more than a hundred
people were hurt
several suffered serious injuries no
group has claimed responsibility
for the attack in france tens of
thousands took to the streets today to
honor a murdered teacher
the demonstrations were sparked by the
death of samuel patty
the history teacher was beheaded on
friday outside his school
by a suspected islamist the suspect was
killed by police
earlier this month patty had shown his
students cartoons of the prophet
muhammad
in a class on freedom of expression
muslims believe
any depiction of the prophet is
blasphemous
protests led by students took over the
streets of bangkok again today
in defiance of a state emergency imposed
across the country
chanting down with dictatorship
activists are calling for the prime
minister's resignation a more democratic
constitution
and a reformed monarchy the
demonstrations are now into their fifth
day despite the arrest of dozens of
protesters
authorities in bangkok have tried in
vain to quell the unrest with the use of
water cannons and by shutting down
the transit system coming up
canada's royal gift to the queen and for
months a ten-year-old boy has been
living
under the stars with a purpose
canada honored its ties to queen
elizabeth today with a new official
portrait
the canadian government commissioned
royal photographer chris jackson for the
image
it was taken last year at windsor castle
in it the queen is wearing a white dress
adorned with her canadian insignia
the sovereign order of canada given to
her in 1970 by then governor general
roland michener and canada's order of
military merit
the portrait will be displayed in
schools government buildings
and canadian embassies harry and megan
are sharing
their own photo the couple unveiled
their first new official portrait
since stepping down from their royal
duties in march they showed some candid
smiles in their california home
the duke and duchess of sussex have been
promoting their appearance
for the time 100 talks series
dutch royals facing heat for taking a
holiday during the pandemic
are bowing to the criticism king wilhelm
alexander and queen maxima flew back to
the netherlands saturday
cutting their vacation to greece short
there was public backlash because their
country
is currently in a partial lockdown
though they didn't violate lockdown
rules
the netherlands discourages any
unnecessary travel
still ahead a new treatment to battle
blindness it may open the door for other
conditions
a groundbreaking gene therapy that can
restore eyesight has now been approved
in canada
it's a major development for people who
have lost vision
due to certain genetically inherited eye
diseases
and assolin go reports this opens the
door for gene therapy to be used to
treat
or prevent other diseases jack mccormick
was born with a faulty gene that's
causing his vision to deteriorate
by high school he couldn't see faces
unless they were right next to him
a few years ago he heard about a
promising treatment in the works
i remember thinking wow like imagine if
this could help me one day and it turns
out it can
and that's really exciting for me health
canada has approved
luxterna a gene therapy that can restore
sight for people with retinitis
pigmentosa
or liber congenital amaurosis if their
mutation is
in a certain gene the treatment is a
surgical delivery
of a genetically modified
virus that carries a normal copy of the
gene
into the eye dr ian mcdonald says in the
ophthalmology world
this is the equivalent of walking on the
moon the copy of the normal gene
replaces the defective one
and starts making the protein the eyes
need before
treatment this patient struggles to walk
through a maze in dim lighting
and one year after treatment the same
test is a breeze
wow they could easily navigate step over
obstacles we're seeing such amazing
results
uh people being able to get their night
vision back
being able to navigate again having
their independence
it's just truly an amazing moment donors
to fighting blindness canada
funded some of the early research that
led to luxterna
now they're hoping the provinces will do
their part by covering it for patients
the one-time treatment is expected to
cost over a million dollars
but the charity says that investment
will save health care
costs in the long run so in the room
right now i can see the cabinet that's
behind me
but i wouldn't be able to necessarily
see say the handles
on it jack hopes to at least save what
little vision he has left
the belief was there's nothing that
could be done about it but that's
changing every day for so many people
it's giving a lot of people hope for the
future
sulingo global news edmonton
up next in a tent for seven months and
counting all for a cause
[Music]
how's this for a balancing act a new
world record has been set in germany and
it's not for the faint of heart
this slackliner crossed the max morlock
stadium in germany at a height of 73
meters
he walked across from one floodlight
pole to another
for a distance of 230 meters breaking
the world record for the longest high
line
in a stadium to another kind
of amazing feat anyone who's ever cooked
up a thanksgiving feast knows
how much work goes into it well a
hamilton teenager has taken over the
task for his family
and the final product is bringing joy to
thousands
this photo of rehan audu posted on
twitter by his older brother
has received hundreds of thousands of
likes the 14 year old spent
two days cooking this meal all on his
own
he started helping his mother with
thanksgiving dinner when he was just
10 but he's since taken over the
delicious deed
a ten-year-old british boy is getting
plenty of attention for a good deed
and he's having quite an adventure while
he's at it he's paying tribute to his
late neighbor by pursuing his passion
for the outdoors
and paying it forward to an organization
that provides comfort
to those who are dying crystal
commansing has that story
spending time outdoors is something
we're all trying to do
as much as possible these days for a
ten-year-old boy a tent
in the backyard is a wonderful bit of
privacy
a pop-up refuge but this isn't a typical
campout it's a tribute he was super fit
he loved the outdoors
max wussey is talking about rick abbott
he used to live next door
he and max were buddies he'd be doing
active things like going to the gym
or going on the water sports like
kayaking and paddleboarding
abbott passed away but how he lived
stirred something in his young neighbor
he started a couple of days after the
beginning of lockdown because we
actually said no
to when he asked the first few nights so
he's been out there since towards the
end of march
this campout is raising tens of
thousands of dollars for
the north devon hospice that helped care
for his friend
the chief executive of the facility
stephen roberts
says max's exploits have been a rare ray
of sunshine
max is an absolute hospice hero
and we're also proud of what he's
achieved
i'm planning to do a year in the tent
and then see where it goes from there
really
then he's coming inside no more i'm not
okay so no end date has been set just
yet
but his mum rachel is proud it started
out just kind of raising money
and raising awareness that actually
these charities are still there and
they're working harder than ever
but their funding has been cut so it's
just sort of everybody needs to support
their local communities
as you can see it's very cold
and very windy max is just a few feet
from a warm
comfortable bed in a room with sturdy
walls
but here inside his tent he's helping to
make life more
comfortable for others while fulfilling
a promise to his friend
he is having an adventure
crystal commencing global news london
there are good people in this world and
that is global national for this sunday
i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is gravelberg
saskatchewan thank you for watching
donna friesen will be here tomorrow have
a great night
you